[Música]
en París hay una escuela como ninguna
otra donde los niños crecen en medio de
la música durante más de 75 años la
matriz de radio France ha permitido que
jóvenes artistas se conviertan en
cantantes de ópera
[Música]
vocalizaciones finales antes del Gran
concierto para andrelia y sus compañeros
bajo la dirección de su directora de
coro de hecho creo que si tiene la
mirada presente están convencidos y
quieren convencer al público todo saldrá
bien con el jefe
de hecho cuando cantas es como cuando
haces deporte
tienes que entrenar tienes que calentar
entonces ahí calenté la voz también Me
aseguré de que las jóvenes recordaran
los puntos importantes a no olvidar
durante el concierto
en unas horas las jóvenes artistas
vivirán su sueño
presentarse junto a la orquesta
filarmónica de radio France
en el programa beglioz un repertorio
exigente
es más emoción pero no miedo porque hay
mucha gente hay cámaras está el director
y la orquesta
[Música]
es un poco de emoción un poco de
Adrenalina entre comillas
de radio francés Es una institución
Parisina que ahora tiene una sucursal en
los suburbios en bondí en San Denis la
escuela olandegus Aquí es donde andrelia
hizo sus primeras escalas es el turno de
Christie 9 años de tomar el relevo en la
clase de cm1 canta bajo la dirección de
Morgan Jordan director del coro de la
metris de bondi
[Música]
lo que desarrollamos particularmente en
la matriz de radio France es una
pedagogía de grupo es el coro Es el
hecho de que cada uno Aprende a ser
igual dentro de un grupo y
constantemente en su enseñanza ya sea en
la formación musical en las clases de
canto en el piano es más aprenden con
los demás
es una forma de escuela de vida de
tras la elección de canto no hay respiro
para las jóvenes artistas con la
imprescindible elección de solfeo
Christi fue audicionada en transición
los profesores de la matriz vinieron a
conocerla en su escuela para identificar
talentos y vocaciones
desde entonces comparte su vida de
colegiala clase por la mañana y clases
de música por la tarde
[Música]
una agenda apretada para la niña pero
vale la pena
[Música]
hacemos grandes conciertos en París
conocemos a celebridades que han cantado
en óperas muy famosas
después visitamos al mismo tiempo
lugares a los que no podemos ir así como
así
luego cantamos durante la visita y es
bueno
mucha gente no se escucha
no te da miedo cuando hay mucha gente
así no tienes miedo escénico sé que
vinieron aquí para escucharnos Entonces
tenemos que cantar bien para que no sea
decepcionen
trabajar siempre para esperar vivir su
sueño y de regreso a casa crístico re
hacia su piano para hacer su tarea de la
tarde una aplicación y una determinación
que son el orgullo de sus padres
nuestra profesora de canto Isabel nos
dio una pieza de canto pero tenemos que
crear la letra
[Música]
vi que ella es más independiente está
muy motivada y no tenemos que estar
detrás de ellos porque tienen un horario
tiene algo que hacer y se dicen allá
vamos tienen que trabajar tienen que
hacerlo paso a paso
cuando escribimos poesía recordamos
mejor porque como hacemos canciones
tenemos que recordar cuando escribes
poesía en la escuela recuerdas más
rápido dentro de unos años Christi
también tendrá la oportunidad de
presentarse como sus mayores en una gran
sala de espectáculos
en la casa de la radio se acerca la hora
del concierto tiene lugar a Puerta
cerrada para el coro de la metéis de
radio France del que forma parte
andrelia es hora de Volver al Backstage
para largos minutos de espera
pero no lo suficiente para impresionar a
la chica cómo te sientes aquí ahora
todavía estás un poco nerviosa
No para nada Andrea y el coro de niñas
suben al escenario aplaudidos por un
lleno total
y pronto las voces de las jóvenes
artistas se elevan afinadas
[Música]
también me da mucha felicidad cantar es
un poco de Adrenalina cuando hago un
concierto con amigos frente al público
frente a tu familia que nunca te ha
visto cantar o tus amigos es para
demostrar que sé cómo hacer esto sé cómo
hacer aquello también estoy orgullosa de
ser parte de la matriz
[Música]
cada año la matriz de radio France
ofrece a 160 chicas o chicos de 7 a 18
años la oportunidad de crecer en la
música y encontrar ese equilibrio entre
el placer y las exigencias de la ópera
[Aplausos]